rampant inflation is forcing the bank of
England to raise interest rates and this
is feeding through into higher mortgage
rates you can see just how much they've
risen over the last year and a half the
average rate on a two-year fixed
mortgage has now hit 6.01 The Five-Year
that's the blue line has also ticked up
and the prospects for homeowners are now
as bad as they were in October just
after the mini budget and comfortable
news for a prime minister who was tasked
with sorting out the mess of his
predecessor
and these rates they're going to stay
higher for longer too look at the peak
on the red line back in May financial
markets thought the bank of England
would start to cut rates by the end of
the year but now if you look at the dark
blue line in the middle well will be
well into 2024 before the bank can even
contemplate that
remember expectations about where the
bank rate will go influence lenders when
they're pricing their products
and all of this will come as a shock to
the more than 2.4 million homeowners
whose fixed deals expire between now and
the end of 2024 households will be
paying on average an extra 2 900 pounds
a year
over the five years to the end of
January 2026 borrowers will have paid an
extra 15.8 billion pounds on their
mortgages that's a lot higher than we
thought back in May
and for people like Megan Johnson a
single mother and Junior doctor whose
mortgage payments are about to LEAP by
300 pounds a month they feel like
they're sitting on a ticking time bomb
I'm actually going back into training in
August which obviously with the news and
the junior doctor strikes my peer is
actually going to take quite a drastic
cut from August so I'm probably gonna
have to work more than ever just to find
the extra 300 pound difference to be
honest so it's going to be quite
um quite difficult really but obviously
just gonna have to juggle it really and
work extra shifts
it's important to properly convey the
scale of this for those who remember
when rates were around 13 in the 1990s
five or six percent may not seem like
lots
but the headline figures don't tell us
everything because people are taking out
much bigger loans these days and when
you adjust for the size of loans
compared to income well it's a very
different picture people taking out new
mortgages today are facing the biggest
home loan squeeze since the housing
crash of the 1990s and the consequences
of this go beyond homeowners
proportionately fewer people own their
own home than 20 years ago but renters
will also be here if landlords pass on
higher mortgage costs to tenants
so it's a bleak State of Affairs for a
country already grappling with the cost
of living crisis the government has
explicitly ruled out providing any
support to homeowners but with a general
election on the horizon
the pressure to do something is
unrelenting